ricky oh my gosh your talk show
was the biggest deal in the like it was
so epic
11 seasons yes 11 seasons with my first
show and one season with my second show
and one emmy
at the end of the day yeah boom
drop that mic emmy thing
i tried to throw that in there a little
shameless plug
okay you had some episode titles that
were totally
iconic and amazing and really wild
and i was wondering if you remember any
of them and if we could play
a little game that we're calling is this
ricky lake or fake based on your show
titles
all right
bring it okay here's how to work i'll
read you a title and you tell us if it's
an actual episode title from ricky lake
or
it's a fake okay okay here we go first
title
i'm in love with my cousin ricky laker
fake
it's fake the answer is no it's oh
it's real oh okay
um next title your promiscuous cat
got my cat pregnant and you're paying
kitten support or
else ricky laker fake i mean it's
derived from maybe one of my shows but
it is not
a real title that is fake the answer is
it's fake
um okay next title i'm a real life
vampire
today i'll prove it ricky lake or fake
i'm gonna say that's real it's real
i don't remember that one but okay um
okay whack em hard smack em down mom you
can't stop them from the backyard
wrestling
ricky lake or fake i think that's
actually a real title
i think that's my show it's a ricky lake
i knew it i knew it
okay i'm getting warmed up now
okay dad i'm in love with a sweet potato
pie and you can't stop me from marrying
yet
ricky lake or fake that's fake that's
fake
yeah it's a fake okay
next title brother sister you think i
look like a circus freak
but chill out because you're a major
geek ricky laker fake
i think that's my show
[Applause]
100 hours of television but that
definitely rings a bell
oh good okay fun okay your eyebrows are
fake and everyone knows it
that's fake it's a fake
okay stop dressing like a teen you're
embarrassing me pastor tom
oh god pastor tom i'm gonna say that's
fake yes it's a thing
how dare you write my number on the
bathroom wall today you will pay ricky
lake or
fake i think it's fake
it's a ricky lake
by the way that i feel like is a lost
art
the riding the bathroom wall situation
i don't know if it's a good thing to
bring back or not but you know
okay if you don't stop giving our baby
tattoos and piercings i'm leaving you
ricky lake or fake
fake yeah it's a fake yeah
you have naked pictures of me and i want
them back now
ricky later fake is that a ricky lake
show title but that was like my favorite
show title of them all
i love that one yes
thank you so much for coming on the show
thank you drew
it's such a pleasure talking to you
today thank you for having me
thank you so much
[Music]